one of the catholic church's oldest
traditions that's pilgrimages was put on
hold last year due to covet now travel
experts say this that faith travel is
rebounding faster and stronger than
other kinds of travel just as it did
after 9 11 and the 2008 financial crisis
chris livesay talks to pilgrims who
explain why they're willing to risk
their physical health for their
spiritual well-being
good morning with the onset of the
omicron variant travel is once again
taking a beating but if there's one kind
of tourist willing to take a leap of
faith that's the religious traveler
coming here and to jerusalem
it's not just a trip to israel it's a
pilgrimage in the footsteps of jesus
so spiritually significant it's worth
the bodily risk of covid says andy craig
from washington d.c christians have been
coming to the holy land for thousands of
years in
far more dangerous conditions
in the middle ages dangers ranged from
marauders to the plague
today there's a pandemic an obstacle but
one worth facing says father roger
landry
for christians our faith makes us bold
you can smile that boldness makes
pilgrims some of the most reliable
travelers in the industry
taking 300 million trips each year a
quarter of all international tourism
according to the u.n and no matter the
catastrophe the faithful traveler is a
faithful customer says john hale the
president of a leading travel company
you know in the years it follows
september 11th it was definitely the
faith-based travelers who came back the
quickest and we're seeing that again
following the pandemic
[Music]
this group from texas is visiting rome
it's been the best marissa acosta says
nothing could stop her after kovid
nearly killed her mom timote loredo this
is like a
mother-daughter treat so your mom is
here she's right there oh wow hello
nice to meet you
so your mom had kovid she did and yet
you came here
anyway weren't you afraid
no we have the bald vaccine even the
booster and
i guess after
seeing her almost died about it
we just are so grateful to celebrating
life what else we can do
now no matter how bold the pilgrim there
are limits the u.s state department
recently advised americans to avoid
travel to italy as cases here continue
to spike for cbs morning's chris livesay
rome